hi
i'm miles and i'm going to show you how
i professionally clean the pool from
start to finish this pool's not looking
too good
i'm gonna get the submersible pump out
straight away pump the water out
and then come back the next day
[Music]
so we are the next day it's empty but
there's like a blanket of algae all over
the pool i'm gonna shovel it all up put
it in buckets
basically the green sludge is after a
pool's been left for
a long time without any chlorine or
any sanitizer in the pool you'll get
algae build up
most of them don't smell that bad but
when it's when when the sludge is really
thick on the bottom
and you like disturb it because
obviously it's
not been disturbed for a long time the
smell that comes out is crazy
[Music]
basically when we had the pool empty we
realized how many frogs there were
i've never seen so many frogs in a pool
before in my life
like every scoop every shovel fall there
was maybe one or two
frogs on on it so we had to get them out
put them on the side of the pool and let
them run off into the bushes
[Music]
uh so we used hydrochloric acid uh
mixed with water so dilute it down get
out the old karcher k4
start pressure washing the pool down
it's all coming up pretty well
at the bottom of the pool there's a main
thing um
there'd been some work done around the
pool like the slabbing and that
obviously there's a lot of leaves gone
into the pool so a lot of mark at the
bottom
and just built up and solidified so that
to be broken up
nothing special was just a screw it like
an old screwdriver from the van
helped to get into it break it up
um and then hoover down
[Music]
so
[Music]
the dirtiest parts on the pool are going
to be the
filters basically they have the water
runs through the filters
continuously or on a timer blue tank is
the filter with
sand in and that keeps the pool water
clean what it does is catches all the
dirt
and the stuff that's floating around in
the pool so
and then once a week once every two
weeks whenever i go under maintenance
you do a backwash
and that gets rid of all the dirt and
anything that's been floating around in
the pool
new sand in cut it open
i'll do five bags of sand for this 24
inch filter
slip the lid back on
so when i do the chemicals and they all
look the same chlorine as weld all just
like sort of white powder
but basically i'm just balancing the
chemicals on the swimming pools when i'm
doing a maintenance
a few bags of salt needed 325 kilo bags
basically what happens when you pour it
in goes through the system
and runs for a salt cell which is just
the chlorine generator
so as it's running through the salt cell
it uses a process called electrolysis
i think i said it right
basically just turned into chlorine for
the pool get a brush out
brush it all around so it's not just
sitting on the floor
and that's that job done
um this was definitely the worst pool
i've worked on
in terms of how dare it was and how much
algae there was
and the smell the smell was just
ridiculous it was unbearable at some
time sometimes it didn't take me all day
it didn't take too long
i know it looks like a lot of mess but
it went pretty well
a lot of people say to me you know don't
you ever just feel like just jumping in
the pool i mean
on a really hot day i do but other than
that i'm not really that bothered about
it
you